The one thing my son can do on his own,
without any help from his parents,
is breathe.
To have medical professionals make the judgment
that Matthew does not need any medical services,
it was outrageous.
It’s just unthinkable.
Who should take care of our nation's sick?
And what happens when an entire public health program gets handed over to private companies?
The privatization of Medicaid has really hurt people who most rely on that program.
And it's very heart wrenching for me.
They're focused on money,
and we're focused on the health of our son.
Welcome to Iowa,
a state that recently privatized Medicaid,
handing control of the entire public health program to for-profit companies.
Iowa's Medicaid system is beginning to collapse.
It's collapsing under the weight of greed.
It raises serious questions about our own humanity.
Hey guys, I’m Kate, and this Sunday we’re in Iowa
to put a face to the people who rely on Medicaid,
and find out what happens when a state puts a crucial social safety net
in the hands of for-profit companies.
Before we get into it, remember, Medicaid’s that federal program established back in 1965
that gives health insurance to our country’s poor, elderly and disabled population.
It’s objectively been a saving grace for millions of Americans.
In Iowa, about 600,000 people are on it,
or about one out of every five people in the state.
One of those people receiving Medicaid is Matthew Hudson,
who had tragic brain bleed which left him completely paralyzed when he was 16.
He’s now profoundly disabled and his parents take care of him.
We have to feed him all his meals, we bathe him,
we have to clothe him. We do all his toileting.
Since the injury 14 years ago, Dave Hudson and his wife have used the Medicaid money
to treat Matthew at their home.
This way, he doesn’t have to go to an institution, which Dave thinks would be more expensive and impersonal.
DAVE: I think I made the decision that Matthew deserved to live the best life possible.
I'm OK with putting my life aside
so that he can have the best possible life.
And that’s how it was for the Hudsons for more than a decade.
But then in 2016, the governor of Iowa at the time,
without any legislative input,
transferred every Iowa Medicaid patient onto plans run by managed care organizations,
or what you’ll hear referred to as MCOs.
The governor said having these for-profit companies handle the state’s $5 billion Medicaid program
would save taxpayers money and ultimately would lead to better care.
But a few months later, the Hudsons got a letter from their new MCO
announcing they were cutting all of Matthew’s care.
Right here: “The reason for the decision is that the information reviewed
fails to establish medical necessity for the requested service.”
When I read that, I couldn't believe it.
You can't be a medical professional and tell me my son does not need any medical services.
What message are these companies sending?
I think the message primarily is,
“We don't care enough about Matt
to pay for the services he needs.
If we're gonna make any money in Iowa, then people like your son
who are expensive and chronically ill,
he's going to be a drain on our profits for as long as he's alive.”
Dave eventually fought the cuts and won. But his struggle isn’t unique.
After the state handed Medicaid over to the health companies,
there have been hundreds of stories of Iowans suddenly being denied crucial coverage,
and then getting stuck in an endless cycle of appeals to get it back.
Every single week,
I get calls from people saying I was denied service of this or that nature.
It's overwhelming, as a reporter.
That’s Jason Clayworth.
He’s an investigative reporter at the Des Moines Register
and has written dozens of stories about the fallout of Medicaid privatization.
One woman even claims that the privatization led to her husband’s death.
JASON: His wife is convinced that had he been receiving the same care that he had received for decades,
that her husband would still be alive.
JASON: These are people that, many times, they can't literally speak for themselves.
Many of these folks are children. They don't understand their rights.
For many of these people, it is a matter of life and death.
These are serious, serious issues.
But here’s the thing: Iowa’s not the only place where this is happening.
In fact, you probably live in a state that’s privatized Medicaid too.
Since the 1980s, 39 states have done so in order to save a buck.
And then what do critics say happens next?
When you get into profit motive, well,
that's your first goal, is to turn a profit.
And if it means you turn a profit at the expense of other people,
you do it.
And by the way, privatization hasn't just meant that patients are worse off.
It’s been a crisis for service providers, too –
places like nursing homes, dental clinics and rehab centers.
Many service providers say they aren’t getting reimbursed from the MCOs,
which means they have to cut back on staff and services.
I've had medical doctors who have called me
who have actually said,
“Up until this point, I always felt it was part of my duty as a doctor to take Medicaid and to serve them.
But I am to the point with frustration with the managed care organizations
where I’m on the edge and ready to just stop taking Medicaid altogether.”
When that happens, families are left with no one to go to for their child’s medical care.
Give it back to the state.
They didn't have problems when the state took care of it.
That’s Joann Facenda.
Her son, Louis, is a 26 year-old with cerebral palsy.
Joann told me that a few months after Louis’s Medicaid was moved to an MCO,
all his care was cut, including his medication.
It was a nightmare.
It was literally a nightmare.
What am I gonna do? I can't afford all that medication.
Also cut were his daily nurse visits.
So for six weeks, Louis went without the in-home bathing and diaper changing he had had for years.
He wasn't getting changed like he would normally get changed, two or three times or more a day.
So he was in a dirty brief from like in the morning til 7 at night.
And all this just because some company decided he didn't need these services.
It wasn't just the services, it was
the mental part of his state of mind –
not understanding why all this was happening.
And I would cry. For him. Because I felt so bad.
At this point, you’re probably wondering how these private companies
have responded to these horrible stories.
Well, listen to how one doctor at one of the MCOs
justified denying diaper changing services.
What would you say to him if he was here?
I would spit in his face, to be honest.
[Louis makes a spit sound]
Yeah. Right, Louis, you like to be clean.
I think it's horrible. I don't have words for that.
I reached out to several people for this video, including the current Republican governor
and the health companies.
No one agreed to speak to me camera.
They also didn’t respond to written questions in an email, either,
but I did get template statements back, extolling the virtues of managed care.
I also tried to reach out to Iowa Medicaid Director Mike Randol – and, by the way,
he’s the same guy responsible for a similar privatization fiasco in Kansas,
which the federal government recently denounced as being “substantively out of compliance" with U.S. law.
Randol explicitly avoided me at a public meeting, but his press department told me in an email:
They also referred me to a study that ranks Iowa’s healthcare system second in the nation
for patient satisfaction,
but Jason told me that study is dubious.
They will cite surveys that they can't provide the specific questions
that were asked or the number of recipients that they asked the question to.
So for all we know, they asked seven people.
We don't know.
No politician will say that they are out to harm the elderly or the poor.
But their actions speak louder than words.
And what about this idea that the state will eventually save money?
Well, in Iowa the estimates of savings have varied wildly, without much explanation.
And a national report on privatized Medicaid showed that, yeah,
some states with managed care did save some money, but that
"the weight of the evidence suggests any potential savings will not be significant.”
And people like Dave Hudson say, even if money is being saved,
on the backs of who?
It doesn't bother me if the number is 1 dollar or 200 million dollars. That doesn't bother me.
What concerns me is where'd the savings come from?
What had to be reduced in order for the state to save $141 million?
My supposition is that the savings came from considerable reductions in Medicaid services.
Everyone should care about Medicaid because every one of us
is an illness or an accident away from needing it someday.
None of us know what our future holds.
But what I do know is that, if that happens to you,
that you have a safety net in place called Medicaid.
My experience with Medicaid in Iowa has only reinforced my belief
that our nation needs to move toward a single-payer, universal system.
I'm not certain that my son is safe
with a Republican governor and a Republican legislator.
The MCOs –
And I say that as a lifelong Republican.
They're focused on money, and we're focused on the health of our son.
Hey everyone, thank you so much for watching Because Facts.
I hope you appreciated this deep dive we did into a pretty complicated topic.
Please remember to like, share and subscribe for more videos like this.
And hey, while you’re at it,
check out some of the coverage that the Des Moines register did around this topic –
it really helped us understand this issue.
You can check a link to their coverage in the description below.
Thank you so much for watching, and we’ll see you next week.